candace bushnell ist die autorin von sex
and the city doch trotz riesen erfolg
der serie viel geld hat die
schriftstellerin damit nicht verdient
mit uns hat sie darüber gesprochen was
sie heute anders machen würde wenn ich
im nachhinein etwas ändern könnte
ich würde härter arbeiten ich hatte eine
fernsehserie sex and the city
das war toll aber ich hatte fünf serien
haben können wenn ich mich nur ein
bisschen mehr angestrengt hätte die
serie hat mich nicht reich gemacht
ich habe damals einen wirklich
schlechten vertrag unterschrieben
ich habe 90 prozent meines geldes
tatsächlich mit büchern verdient
[Musik]
mai heißt wenn du es kann ja nie wissen
sie mein ehemann war zehn jahre jünger
ich habe genug von jüngeren typen
neu war bei kinder allerdings wie viel
jünger die männer waren sie waren in
ihren zwanzigern meine freundin und ich
wir waren in unseren 50ern
das ist wirklich anders teilweise liegt
es vielleicht auch daran dass frauen in
ihren 50ern mehr auf sich achten und
auch besser aussehen als manche frauen
in den zwanzigern
aber ich glaube das hat auch etwas mit
pornos zu tun denn daher kommt die idee
dass ältere frauen für jüngere männer
sexy sein können ja das phänomen der
milch
sexy die young boys jetzt nachholen